hey happy Saturday you guys yeah quit
pandemic update like I said I think
people are following the [ __ ] I don't
think we have to update news if they
want to yeah we're just kind of talking
about I don't know it's not really much
going on in our local area like I said
we haven't really been out for a couple
days so I don't know everybody every
normal everything is everybody from the
show send me photographs of their local
grocery stores yeah you know it's like
it's funny cuz like you know there's
plenty of food but they're just buying
it up they're panicking well yeah what
is that no one could eat that much tea
not if you're not in California or or or
New York or Chicago I really wouldn't
worry I'm not even sure I'd really worry
if I was maybe bad worried if I was in
California but but I mean if you if you
already have food and supplies in your
house it would probably just do better
to just stay where you were
yeah and then maybe later when you run
out or when you start to run out then
maybe go back out don't just go be
buying up stuff that like other view
might need just because you think you
might need it and yeah they're not
letting people they're not letting
people buy more than two things a toilet
paper well they've been doing that for a
long time it's like I said I even
checked cuz I was curious we didn't need
any toilet paper but I was curious after
everybody was freaking out about so I
went to like a slightly less obvious
website which would be staples which if
you're not for the United States as
office supplies and they had big packs
of like 48 rolls of toilet paper or
something like that and they still had
some but they were also limiting it and
that was like a week ago yeah so they've
been doing that for awhile I think Sam's
has been doing that last time when did
we drive by Sam's we didn't go in Sam's
or we did but only for a second we're
like [ __ ] possibility well we went to
the liquor store next to it and it was a
madhouse on a Monday or a Tuesday I
think it was it was like check out this
big ol long lines and I was like man you
know they got a nap and we didn't need
and we didn't need a lot of things I
only needed like cat food and like one
other thing and I'm like I can get that
anywhere I'm just
I'm not dealing with this because I
figured I'd be waiting in line for like
hours and hours yeah my name my neighbor
has walking to the to to the mailbox to
the mailbox my neighbor was standing out
there he's out there in his lawn chair
and I says so you ready for this and
he's like no I'm an and I said I warned
you I because yeah you told me and I
said yeah I told you go get your [ __ ] he
doesn't have any [ __ ] so now he's gonna
be out there with his wife just yeah
there's no food in the grocery store
yeah had all those kids and I said I
told you this dude I was ready weeks ago
like I said we always have extra food he
listened and I said yeah this and I was
thinking about court we're here asking
for food yeah I mean we've had like I
said we have a whole pantry full of
stuff we have a freezer full of seven
we've always had that it's an early yeah
we always kind of had a good stock yeah
just in case yeah yeah but you know in a
week or in a week or so once the panics
over it's it's just gonna be normal like
I said so one thing cuz like hey if you
guys have anything you want us to talk
about our questions you want us to
answer something like that you can
totally do that um you know to give us
ideas for these little daily shows that
we're doing so what person on YouTube I
think it was a YouTube or Facebook asked
me to do book recommendations because I
guess now that you can see all my
bookshelves back in these aren't even
all my books I have like a bunch of my
compositions well damn story oh yeah and
I have some up in the attic also yeah
cuz I have so so many yeah oh man you
were down there pushing on the boxes
well yeah well it wouldn't have been
much good for me to go up there to the
attics not really big enough for a loo
to people to what [ __ ] I was expecting
their rope to come down if that was that
um
that was in San Pedro California what it
was it I think it might have been I
think I read about at my book I was the
one they based the entity on it was it I
think pretty sure no I think that was
two separate things was it but it was
that same investigator yeah I think it
was the same University I mean if I
might be remembering it wrong but I'm
pretty sure that those were two sets
maybe yeah no I don't think it was
but yeah so somebody asked me to do book
recommendation so I might do that like
on some of these I decided today I just
kind of went around and plucked a few
random books off of my shelves I did
like a classic one like classic fiction
I did like a more modern fiction and I
did a nonfiction because I have a lot of
nonfiction probably more than anything
else so the first one I'm going to
recommend if you have not read this you
should this is a classic of Gothic
mystery literature this is the woman in
white by Wilkie Collins this book kicks
ass I was just so so invest in this I
think I read it over one weekend and
look how long it is because I was just
like it's kind of like it starts out as
like sort of a ghost story but then goes
in kind of like a crime mystery like
poisoning type of thing it does not
surprise me in the least that this guy
who was actually a contemporary of
Charles Dickens and they were friends
this book outsold Charles Dickens by
quite a large margin look when it came
out and I'm not surprised I have to say
I like this a lot better than most of
the Dickens that I've know she you know
it's like Dickens is okay but I liked
this much better and there's also a book
I think it's by um Robert Simmons called
Drude that is about it's like a
fictionalized supernatural account of
Wilkie Collins and Charles Dickens like
fighting like a supernatural monster I
kind of wish they would make a Netflix
series out of that because I would watch
the [ __ ] out of that it would be [ __ ]
awesome it's the same author that did
the terror you know also this is another
fiction I just found this book [ __ ]
randomly I think it was in Barnes
Annelle because I used to get a Barnes
ennobling like troll the you know the
the front part where they have like all
those hard backs and stuff that they're
selling off for cheap like once the
paperback comes out I had actually never
heard of this guy but this book is
[ __ ] amazing it's called the Church
of dead girls and it's kind of like it's
like a murder mystery that takes place
in like a small town in upstate New York
and it's like this woman that's found
with like no hand and then like all
these girls start turning it up turning
up and then he's really good at like
kind of ramping up the tension you know
what I mean and like everybody starts
getting paranoid about that somebody in
the town is a killer and like they start
doing vigilante [ __ ] and like all this
other kind of stuff but it's really
really good it's um you know the
suspense just builds up and builds up
I actually liked this so much that I
bought another one of his books called
Boy in the water which is also excellent
I need to read more I read more of his
stuff cuz he's written a [ __ ] ton of
novels and poems and stuff - I think
he's slightly better known as a poet but
he's written a lot of novels as well and
this is my nonfiction and I love this
[ __ ] out of this book and I wish
somebody would make a movie out of this
[ __ ] cuz I would watch the [ __ ] out of
that also this is called strapless and
this is a biography of the woman who
posed for the very famous John Singer
Sargent
portrait called madam X which I have
actually seen in New York and it's
amazing but this woman's life is just
it's so fascinating to me she was just
like she's from New Orleans she was a
Creole and she was kind of like I want
to say like one of the Kardashians of
her time you know I mean because she
wasn't she just was kind of like a
society girl who was really done well
appreciating this like super super pale
skin and she had this like really um
striking look and like the way she
dressed and everything like that so she
was like kind of high up in society and
she was also kind of a snot a little bit
and she was in some other so like some
other artists painted her too just
because she was super famous and it's
funny because this portrait ruined her
life which is very funny because you
wouldn't think about it now because it's
so but the little strap the reason this
book is called strapless is because the
little strap that's off of the dress
that was a huge [ __ ] deal
when this portrait was first displayed
like to the public everybody flipped the
[ __ ] out because they thought oh well
that's like when the strap comes up like
like she's just had sex and put the
dress back on her but she was getting
ready to say
off so it was like this humongous
scandal and she had to like basically go
into hiding and it's like she she
flipped out so much that she like had to
get rid of all the mayor she wouldn't
look at herself anymore and like all
this other kind of stuff so it's like
there's some people give a [ __ ] yeah so
there's like some fictional novels
because I've read a couple of those kind
of about it but this is like the you
know the nonfiction like biography of
her and it's really really good and like
I said I wish somebody would make it
into a movie because I think it would be
really awesome she's not a likable
person but she's a really interesting
person you know what I'm saying
I guess aside from that we're watching
the Elvis movie
yes Dominic sent us that a John
Carpenter yeah Elvis movies that came
out what 1977-78 it was but I looked it
up earlier because I was curious it was
but it was after Halloween but before
the fog so Halloween was 78 so it's like
79 okay
79 80 something like when did the fog
come out 79 or 80 so it was somewhere in
there and it's funny because um I think
Rob sent me a link and he's like some
website somewhere had like ranked every
John Carpenter movie like from what from
best/worst or whatever and some of the
movies in there I had forgotten that he
had directed them yeah it doesn't feel
like a carpenter movie it's very
straight-laced it's very it's almost
kind of like a documentary in a way it's
yeah it's it's like no frills and that's
not like a at all it's like three and a
half almost four hours long yeah I
didn't realize it was like Salem's Lot
length yeah it's good though it's in
it's accurate it's very accurate based
on everything that I've read and heard
about the king I call McCain Mississippi
well yeah it's the law they're ruining
all Mississippi you know you have to
understand that Elvis is a deity
he's religious deity you know he's up
there with Jesus no no not exactly there
but it's almost kind of like John the
Baptist he's like what not SFIL yeah
like John the Baptist you know and it's
three different are incarnations
you know I mean because he returned as a
Ryan and Billy Idol
Glalie I know I guess you wanna go there
there were sequels to Elvis yeah yeah
I'm really liking it we actually I
didn't realize because I should have
because it was made for TV but it was a
TV miniseries so I'm assuming it aired
like over two or three nights like I
said like Salem's Lot did so we just
started watching it we're watching it
and then like we paused it like to go to
the bathroom or something like that I'm
like holy crap this still has like - I
think it's like four hours what I liked
about it is that it reminded me it kind
of put him into a context of how retro
Elvis was he was retro even back in when
he in the day and the day he was retro
I mean took his parents with him
wherever he went yeah you know he buys a
brand new manche and he puts mom and dad
and grandma up at Graceland with him
living in there today today as a
celebrity wouldn't do that yeah I'd be
like yeah you buy you buy a house and
live separate house for them yeah you
you guys go live over there and don't
visit me this was very family-oriented
he had to be in his mama's face all the
time
yeah Shelley Winters places yeah he was
kind of a mama's boy
a little bit and they do show that in
this and it's a little bit weird but not
in a not in a creepy way it's just more
kind of like you know it's like he was
like a Victorian or something from
another country yeah it was kind of
heartwarming but also from a modern
perspective it's kind of weird but I
actually I think Kurt Russell makes a
really good Elvis he's not doing the
singing in this one because we looked
that up somebody else does it it sounds
just like those it really does it sounds
a lot like him but I mean there are a
couple scenes where crustle kind of lays
it on a little thick words words an
Elvis impersonation like a little bit
like a carrot he says one more too much
total moment he says mumbled too many
times at a dam in a sentence and it's
just but it is caught you know it he did
a really good job he looks a lot like
Elvis man I never realized until they
get until they gave him like the
pompadour hair and like even like
especially like his profile and stuff
like that when he was really young like
that he was in the army
yeah I was like holy crap he does really
look a lot like I'll there's no that I'm
thinking about it you know it's funny
it's like we were watching the movie
this happens to us all the time because
we're getting old and it will happen to
you youngsters too but we'll be watching
a movie and we'll see like
actor in there and we'll be like goddamn
but we just saw them in something it's
like remember I was talking about in
satanic panic like the girl that played
Judy it was bugging me the whole time so
I'm like I just saw her in a [ __ ]
movie wasn't it I had to look it up but
it was happy deathday yeah well why
don't want to help us his old
girlfriends from Memphis that he never
really sees again once he leaves yeah
Bonnie I think turns out Bonnie played
Dale Arden in flash board yeah because
the whole is like we just I know I've
seen her like I said I've seen her in a
movie that I've seen a bunch of times I
was think for some reason I was thinking
80s slasher movie cuz I've been watching
a lot of those recently I'm like maybe
she was in prom night or yeah and I said
not prom night but something like that
and then finally I told him I was like
pause the movie look it up but I am t
because they drive me crazy for the rest
of the movie nothing I liked about the
movies that they left the paranormal
elements to to help us Presley in there
and there is some paranormal [ __ ] with
with Elvis Elvis cuz swore that his
mother knew exactly what he was doing no
matter where he was and they did like
bring they give him a little bit of a
miserable column you know and so you
know I dreamt there was a fire and that
the women were ripping your clothes off
yes yeah they did have yeah like their
car overheated yeah there's not you know
and then another one that was kind of
paranormal is that you know his twin
died yeah I think at birth wasn't it or
just right yeah well yeah when he was a
baby so he he evidently talked to this
ghostly twin Jesse yeah Jesse and he
felt that Jesse was with him and he
kinda and his mom believed that that
basically his mom believed that Elvis
had two souls in him yeah or the power
of two souls so there's just some weird
[ __ ] you know it's like some stuff that
would happen now that must be Amazon
yeah which pause ringing yeah okay that
was a Amazon delivery but yeah I like
the fact that they left kind of some of
the paranormal stories associated with
Elvis I mean you know growing up in
Mississippi for the summers that run
into kids you know like I think I told
this story before yeah they actually
thought he could cause it to rain yeah
that's what their parents told them I
just thought of and I think I mentioned
this we were talking about it before I
said that's such a weird like a weirdly
specific superpower like you tell this
you would think that I don't know I like
I don't know if Elvis had a superpower
what would it be like that had something
to do with his Elvis Ness
I wouldn't making it rain would not be
the first thing that would occur to me
I'm not sure what would occur to me
later on as his career started to kind
of wind down you know he started to sing
gospel yeah so that kind of a religious
element got cast over Elvis yeah in the
dot in the deep south yeah you know so I
think it kind of merged he became
mythical oh yeah and then I died you
know what I mean they thought that maybe
he would come back where he wasn't dead
and then he had Elvis impersonators who
were really good releasing albums you
know and Orion was like one of the best
ones you guys can go on YouTube and look
up Orion you know Elvis impersonator and
he sounds just like Elvis I mean just
like it yeah wore a mask so you couldn't
tell right B look he wore a mask so you
couldn't tell it wasn't Elvis but people
were holding out that maybe it was Elvis
yeah and that's an interesting story
it's and yeah there's a documentary
about it I don't know if you can still
get it anymore I don't even remember
where we saw it because that was a while
back but yeah it's it's really good
we've kind of think we've talked about
Orion before but yeah yeah and the the
albums kind of had resurrection themes
and occult themes on them yeah goes to
try to get to try to insinuate to people
that he had risen from the grave yeah
which that's unfair come that's some
weird [ __ ] when you think about it I do
kind of feel like in a thousand years
some of us will have a whole like like a
religion around him probably people were
going to see him and they were kind of
wanted to believe that yeah that he had
risen everybody Time Machine just yeah
and she worked in Mississippi yeah and
then later once he Suzy Turk took the
mask off and told her buddy who he
really was his career was over
then he bought a pawn shop and got
killed in a poncho I got shot in the
[ __ ] rubber shot in the Rob Reider
pawn shop
came in to rob a pawn shop yeah yeah it
wasn't a happy story no no no but he was
a great singer I just call him Orion
yeah that's everybody
Ryan yeah yeah I probably I'll think of
it a minute but yeah um if you guys cuz
everybody I think everybody that knows
me knows like I'm a big Nick Cave fan
and he had a song called tupelo which is
on his album the firstborn is dead which
is also a reference Alvis is twin
brother yeah and the whole theme of the
song Tupelo is like about Elvis's twin
brother dying elvis taking upon himself
the both good and evil aspects like the
twin soul thing like his mom was talking
about and it also makes like a jesus
mythology out of him also so yeah so
that so it's very prevalent so prevalent
that like you know a cave who is
Australian in case you didn't know
Tupelo isn't very far from where my dad
was born and where is going for the
summers but there's nothing there
there's nothing in Tupelo yeah I don't
think there was anything in Tupelo
during the time when Elvis was I had a
friend that lived there in the 70s or
80s but they moved away and she was
pretty young it's like little farm house
type things the downtown area is very
small
yeah it's only downtown yeah our little
enclosed community here with Dwarfs down
to bigger than I remember it mostly just
being a square yeah
roads in a square with in a park in the
middle and just like two big dollar
stores right yeah it's a dollar store
yeah yeah
dollar store there's a lot of towns like
that like a little hardware store
southwest yeah and there might be like a
Piggly Wiggly Georgia story don't
believe that's a reality I didn't know
they were still around but yeah I got I
got a bag from it I'm gonna have to take
and down next time we go to the grocery
store might take my Piggly Wiggly bag
yeah I keep forgettin well that was the
last time I saw it you know if you base
from to plum sure you can look at it on
Google Earth now but yeah last time I
saw it you know I was I was even before
I was in the army yes a long time ago so
I don't know what it's like now but
there yeah
I don't remember anything being there
maybe there's more to it now didn't you
get two didn't get to see it yeah but
I've pretty much I'm pretty sure that I
drove right down through the middle of
the downtown my dad I think drove you
through there it might only be witnessed
nowadays because that's where Elvis is
from yeah there's probably statue in
there but I don't really remember fresh
shrines
there's gotta be yeah I mean I would be
very surprised if there wasn't it was
real slow and sleepy when I went through
it yeah yeah but yeah so if you haven't
seen it like John Carpenter it's good
luck made a TV movie have like a TV
miniseries we haven't seen that final
one-third of it good yeah we saw we just
watched like the first I think we
watched the first few hours and I think
there's like an hour an hour and a half
left right or something like that yeah
pretty long it's when he tries to reboot
his career after his mom and dad after
his mom and dad all right
you want to knock off for the Saturday
cuz we got some other [ __ ] we got to do
the show and we're gonna yeah actually
later on tonight we're gonna make some
cocktails and yeah do the show video do
the show yeah well actually you have to
like hang my cool mirror and stuff like
that and that gap back there yeah I'll
have to hang that up so it'll be in the
background that Kennedy alright so we'll
talk to you guys again later